two major artists altered the lyrics to  their songs they erased the word spaz in  post-production this is a rapidly  advancing New Frontier for the  suppression of free speech and artistic  expression it's something Beyond burning  books something Beyond destruction it's  stories and songs and films cut apart  and written over leaving no trace and no  remnant of whatever used to be if  somebody like Beyonce does not take a  stand on her right to create as she  pleases there's very very little hope  for anybody else including artists who  are just emerging who are just  developing and trying to take risks but  can't or are too afraid to